foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of
Fight Night flash back I'm here with the
living legend himself Eric Griffin
you're basically a black belt uh UFC
fights now after doing this if you think
I'm still what is it what are the levels
your white belt two stripe white belt
well I might Blue Bell I think blue blue
yeah they're blue blue belt because
people people hit me up now Griff you're
watching the fights this weekend and I'm
not there yet like when you only watch
the major ones no it's not even that
actually it's it's until is when we do
this
like I'll do this and then I'll be like
you're telling me about all if I'm like
oh and then I I'm like well I gotta
watch it well this one particular that's
why I picked you for this one because
that's what I think me or Brian Patty's
a fun one this one I think you're gonna
dig more because you got Izzy anasanya
the style Bender versus Alex Pierre and
Izzy's the reigning middleweight champ
and he hasn't a lot of people give him
problems he's been a dominating champ
but the reason why this one's
interesting because the guy's fighting
Alex Pierre scary scary Brazilian they
both have a kickboxing background and
they fought way before they were both in
the UFC and this ax Pierre actually beat
him knock them out so this the Alex
Pierre finally went to MMA he won like a
one fight in LFC and then UFC signed
them because they need more fresh meat a
better story for Izzy because he's
beating everybody there's not a lot of
questions
this guy that's Robert Whittaker so
we're gonna the first fight we're gonna
do with Izzy so I'm gonna I'm gonna show
you Izzy I'm gonna show you here I'm
gonna show you the fight where they
fight each other but the reason why I
think it connects with with Izzy is
because he's a gamer he's a streamer oh
really he's really big into anime his
walkouts are the best walkouts he's he's
a showman big time Big Big Time and we
could show you one of his walkouts is he
undefeated
uh in the UFC correct yep oh well he
lost light heavyweight but in
middleweight he's undefeated yeah if
aliens came down to earth right now like
hey what who's give us one fighter to
watch in the FC it would be Izzy oh to
me he's the most technical best fighter
dude his his stand-up is insane I gotta
say this though man
I what I've noticed from doing this and
when we talk about these guys who are
undefeated and then they're about to do
something big uh you know the UFC's got
him at a point now where they're gonna
this is the next step they end up losing
it's tough It's like three times in a
row now they've lost his goal was to
shoot for the shoot for the moon and
fight Jon Jones I like heavyweight and
they gave him yawn which is just a tough
matchup for me end up losing but he's
still the middleweight champ of the
world and to be honest with the UFC
where they're at now he's probably the
biggest star they got he's massively
massive all right yeah he's from New
Zealand but of African descent but I
feel like we were just talking about
this with the guy from the you know the
Ukraine or whatever the guy that you
know he was supposed to fight Nick Diaz
and he didn't
like this walkout this was an Undertaker
thing
and then he's done one where he walks
out he used to be a b-boy so he walked
out with his old friends who were b-boys
and did a dance before he walked through
the octopus he gets it oh dude look at
him holding the base oh he can't take
care of the whole Undertaker sound no I
get there and then he doesn't lose
either that's the thing like you can do
this but if you lose you look like an
[ __ ] I think even if you lose at
least you're putting on a show he's a
showman yeah he'll talk some smack too I
think there's a part of this that the
UFC has learned I think that these
Fighters This is a millennial thing this
is like knowing like this is how people
connect and that's why Jake Paul's so
big yeah because he came into the the
weigh-ins on a horse like it's a it's a
it's a show it's a circus a bit of it so
this is the first right so this man that
he's fighting this is in Melbourne
Australia at the time off it still is it
was the biggest live gate the UFC's ever
had really so Robert Whittaker's
Australian Izzy's from New Zealand
represents Izzy via Africa but he's New
Zealand right so uh Robert Whittaker
outside Izzy is the best middleweight on
the planet this this is how this fight
went watch how good this guy is but I'm
just asking me ask you this though uh
and you think that the middleweight
division is the best division in UFC
it's up there right it's because of
because of the the amount of Fighters
that the range of stocks yeah but really
after the heavier you go the less uh
stack the the division is because
there's just not a ton of heavyweights
all the best athletes in America around
the world aren't really fighting
especially in America so the lower
weight classes have more options but
middleweights where you still have power
and you have size but it's stacked so
you'll see is he here so the guys Robert
Whittaker's Savage Savage athletic is a
very Taekwondo stance team on the ball
his feet Izzy's the the taller he's tall
for the division two but he's known for
his distance and and well he's got long
ass arms yes and he knows how to use it
and what do you think about him slamming
himself into the gate like that every
single time yeah he's going back right
now but Robert Whittaker is so explosive
it's tough for him to get out of the way
but you'll see a lot of it's missing but
what makes Izzy special you'll see he
throws a lot of smoke like we had Marvin
Victoria on food truck he was like when
I fought him it was just a it was tough
I didn't know what was coming there's so
much to get through he confused me so
much it was just by the time I figured
out it's too late and what's his
expertise
striking kickboxing okay he's good with
his legs good with his hands on the
ground though uh his takedown defense is
really good but you know we really
haven't seen him tested on the ground
when he went to light heavyweight it was
more of a size thing but in the
middleweight division no one really
takes him down and if they do he gets
back to his feet so he just wants to
fight on the feet at all times that's
why the fight we're talking about UFC
281 the main event against Alex Pierre
Alex Pierre doesn't want to go the
ground either Alex way worse than uh
Izzy is on the ground Alex what do you
think what do you think where does he
have the most Advantage Alex yeah uh
probably I would say he probably has a
power Advantage oh his power Advantage
but the thing is about Alex is he
doesn't have the same experience at the
high level like Izzy does and I think
and Izzy he's a slight favorite but
barely man and Alex is really big too so
he's gonna have a a power Advantage you
see see how he wobbled in there so he is
a counter Striker but then when he hurt
you he'll get a little more aggressive
like you see him going forward here
Izzy's the best in in the middle of the
Octagon he kicks a lot yeah man world
class kicker world class
oh
doesn't look like it's a lot of power in
this punch but I'm sure that it is it
adds up yeah but that would the Alex is
definitely you wouldn't count him you
wouldn't say he's a power puncher no uh
yeah he don't have a ton of finishes but
he's also fighting the very best of the
best in the world he needs them to be
aggressive he needs them to no he Ducks
nobody he needs them to be aggressive
because when they're aggressive they
come in that's when he lights him up
oh he's got long legs too good he's
lanky yeah man he's a big boy from what
I've seen I would look at this and I
would think that that's not a uh an
ideal UFC body
for yeah how thin he is yes yeah and the
other guy again you might watch all this
inside with Alex Pierre which a lot of
the fan base is just because he's so big
and powerful but I think people are
making a mistake because that Alex
Pierre hasn't filed at the same level
that Izzy has oh because this guy he's
fighting oh wow Daddy's fighting
literally this guy looks like a little
rock though yeah second best
middleweight in the world but notice
this guy's you're like damn this guy's
kind of teeing off him eventually is he
downloads you know what you're doing and
knocks out if you take too many chances
he's Gonna Knock You Out the only time
you get a boring fight is when the guy
doesn't engage with him because Izzy you
know he wants to lead you into things
oh man I just feel like if one of these
hits oh yeah
and I got no less a knockout artist
that's what he looks like yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying it looks like
he's trying to so does this guy's his
defense good like he doesn't get oh a
lot oh wow look at that
that's it get them off get them off yep
huge one frizzy look at him
showman Showman oh man he is lanky as
hell dude yep I can tell you used to be
a dancer because he's like he can move
with the Matrix right there his b-boy
walkout was epic can you see The
Knockout again because it was it that
was so many people are there bro biggest
live gate in UFC history
and there's Paulo Costa who we're going
to get to next so that's the other guy
who at the time was undefeated coming up
to fight is also so he so he came to
does that happen a lot like yeah fighter
sit in ringside
and Izzy's like a really good dude boom
Oh that was you would think that man
you would think that that wouldn't be
the punch but wow there was he
left-handed uh what the answer about him
is he can go traditional or South he's
gonna boom
boom that's the one oh and they're both
right he's playing the game now wow
right yeah
it's like he's so lanky that he's just
like it's almost like boom he just slung
it back
he's quicker than anybody fights too
like he's a problem man okay look at him
he's like
and it's been interesting too because
people give him Flacco decision you win
by decision Daddy's champ and people
don't realize once you become the champ
you're getting life-changing money like
he's making millions and millions of
fights so people like you fight safer
not your Champion like yeah [ __ ] I'm
not taking the same chances I got here
with chances but now we're fighting yeah
exactly okay so the guy we're watching
now was the guy that was in this yes
Paulo Casa who's straight up knockout
and he's undefeated at this time well to
get here yeah he's on the first team all
body
I gotta say just from the eye test I
would look at this and I would think
that this other guy's gonna win the
fight yeah yeah yeah yeah it looks like
a young Vitor Belfort like he's it looks
like Vitor says Dad he's just a Savage
and he's a good follower on Twitter too
he roasts people he's funny
oh this so this is a real [ __ ] talker so
going into the fight there's a ton of
[ __ ] talk a ton of it
yes but you see how Izzy uses his his
his size yeah yeah yeah he's keeping
yeah he keeps not the end yeah I'm about
to say it was like it looks like a
boxing jab you know what I mean to keep
people away look at the kids oh the kick
is vicious yep and no see how he
switches from South Paul to traditional
look at this
Savage man
this other guy's uh beefy yeah he's he's
packing a camel toe you know what I mean
get your nuts out of my face yeah I do
he looks like me in that Rick and Morty
outfit good grief man that's all I can
focus on
[Laughter]
the Brazilian burrito in his pants
extra potatoes taco right now
he doesn't seem to get hit in the face a
lot either he doesn't get hit but he
because of his size he can lean back and
get out of the way but do you think one
hit though
have you seen him take a hit yet yeah
we've seen him get because he fought
Kelvin gaslim it was a war might be my
favorite middleweight fight of all time
and he passed the test ended up beating
him but that was a war man War since
that he really doesn't fight like that
anymore he's more calculated I was about
to say he does look very very focused on
what what's happening like he has to be
Apollo costume he has to be because of
his knockout Powers he can be the same
with Alex Pierre but then also with Izzy
he comes from a camp where it's right
now the number on Camp because they have
Izzy who's world champion they have Kai
care of France who's right up there lost
his last fight but still beast and then
he also they also have Alex volcanovsky
who's the champ he's fighting for the
155 I would think if I was fighting this
guy that you I would try to get him down
on the ground in his last fight he
fought a wrestler
you know it's it's tough it's tough to
get them down there's takedown fence
really good the issue is if you do get
them down and you can lay on top of them
that that's where you're going to win
rounds that's the only way really to
beat them the one guy you can beat him
on the feet who we have you know the
history of it is that Alex Pierre who's
just as dangerous on the feet but I just
feel like when it comes to MMA Izzy
might have a little more of a of a
advantage
this guy's already bleeding yes and as
he doesn't get tired either
like Champion there's a reason that
middleweight why he's such a Savage yeah
I mean this is like
but you see what uh Paulo Casa is doing
he's just letting him like kick do
whatever he wants once you let Izzy take
control of the fight and gets confidence
that's when you're [ __ ]
like you see him here you think he said
like what what's the strategy going in
against this guy though
uh get him down get him down don't take
chances going forward like Robert
Whitaker you get knocked out you gotta
somehow get him down get him grappling
more again easier said than done yeah I
mean I feel like every knockout hit like
that is somebody being aggressive and
not following through watch how
aggressive Apollo causes because you and
as he wants you to come and take chances
he's throwing all this smoke at you all
this especially because that left was
vicious yeah so he got a left and a
right oh yeah both sides both dangerous
you'll see him constantly switch
oh this guy's getting tore up yep see
and see the speed every time I watch one
of these fights there's a moment boom I
was just about to say I saw this see it
in their face yes
every single one of these fights
okay you got you got you're done you're
done you get them now he's humping them
he's talking all that [ __ ] and he's
humping him like a dog and then also
lift his leg up like a dog and piss on
him
it's fantastic
let's take a little break from me
chatting here Griffin's air off about
izi arasanya and uh Pierre all right
because I'm here to tell you man have
you started shopping yet the holidays
are coming up and you're lit you guys
are waiting but just shouldn't man
because the only thing is between now
and December is a bunch of crowds at the
mall there's kids screaming you have
freaking 11 minutes find parking there's
Karen's caring we got it man the list
goes on and right now you can shop early
skip this dress snack some of the best
deals on the season on something
everyone will love I'm talking about
premium audio product from my friends at
raycon whether you're looking for a gift
everyone needs or a stocking stuffer
that's not a candle for once raycons are
the way to go they're wireless earbuds
headphones speakers offer premium sound
useful features and almost custom
comfortable fit they're the only earbuds
wireless earbuds that fit my weird
tortellini ears because of cauliflower I
swear by them I put them on when I'm on
my bike ride I listen to podcasts Us in
the podcast or books on the plane I do
everything in my RAID cons man alright
plus raycon makes it easy with holiday
gift guides for everyone in your life
alright with your mom your dad you got a
fitness lover a gamer and they're like
man I can't find any of that fit that's
where raycon got you covered man all
right and you can find Ray Conn's in
store right now like Kohl's or Walmart
but let me tell you right now you're
always going to get the best deal when
you use my special link buy raycon
that's
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n.com shop schab the
raycon wireless also offers buy now pay
later options so if you're worried about
that we got you covered right now go to
buy raycon.com get 20 off and you'll
save even bigger and get 30 off raycons
exclusive holiday bundles that's by
raycon.com for 20 off your raycon
purchase buy recon.com
this episode of Fight Night flashbacks
is also brought to you by happy hippo we
talking Kratom I swear by Kratom I love
Kratom but you can't trust everyone you
can trust my friends at happy hippo it's
my Limitless pill I use it when I do
stand up when I do podcasts and do
everything man they got me covered it
gets my brain going daddy it helps me
out it's all natural they have great
flavors whatever you're looking for
gummies powders pills my favorites the
high concentrated shots they have the
Cherry shot which I love they have the
pink lemonade happy hippo is for
everybody visit happyhippo.com use promo
code thick boy you get 20 off for life
you can use that code as many times you
want share with your friends your family
that's happyhippo.com for the best
Kratom on the freaking planet promo code
thick boy 20 off for Life use it
whatever you want share with your
friends Aunts Uncles cousins stepmoms
step dads I don't care happyhippo.com
promo code thick boy twin stop for life
now let's get back to the program
there's moments in these fights where a
guy gets hit he gives his best and then
takes a hit and then he has you could
feel like oh man I I can't beat this
yeah yeah they get him like oh yeah he
just had I saw it yeah
oh he's just talking smack he can't hear
what he's doing now to be fair Holocaust
to talk to all this [ __ ] coming in the
fight he just finished him yeah but the
knock on him is oh you can't finish
anybody you have no power so that's why
he's always like no power no Pat that's
him talking about he's like no power I
have no power just knock this [ __ ] out
um
um he gets a lot of flack he's a lot
look at him dance look at him dance
that's come on you can't knock me out
and then do the windmill next to me but
also on Paula Casa get up because then
keep dancing like that like you got to
get up and get out of there otherwise
you can keep celebrating
that body though don't quit does it I
mean yeah he's even he it's almost like
he's trying to get his GQ he's like I'm
just gonna be here
oh man
but like at what point do you think that
these Fighters oh that was it oh I've
never seen a good that was the one you
could lose his face look at this oh he's
like oh man I can't beat this dude
there's the jab you keep talking about
that jab is still that's what I'm saying
this side boxing jab he's got hitting
him with
boom right behind the ear wobbled them
and they say no I'm good no you're not
again that was a left yep built his
defensive left is deadly yeah that's two
times now let's finish the fight okay
here's my question
so these Fighters at what oh that's just
that's not right
somebody's gonna hurt him yeah he's
gonna get hurt so do these Fighters
can they are they smart enough to like
not have an ego and stay with a fight
plan like how hard is it the Champions
are how hard is it to do that how hard
is it to be like I just I want like like
to be like Floyd Mayweather yes like
stick to the planet
the guys who are Champion stick to it
that's what that's what in DC uh
articulated this the best he was saying
the difference between the fir the
number one ranked Guy The Champ and the
15th guy is all mentality so when you
get in they stick to a game plan it
might go south but they still stick to
the game plan because they know that's
the best way to get to Victory all right
now so now this is the guy this guy is
fighting he looks [ __ ] scary
everybody's on his nuts right now on
Instagram he's a good follow because
he's making fun of Izzy and he does have
the the KO finish over him as well
but again the the thing is about Alex
Pierre he had the easiest route to get
to a title because it's a good story so
he won I think three fights and then
they gave him Sean Strickland which is a
perfect match-up form and he knocked
Strickland out which we'll see after
this fight but again Izzy's not a
wrestler so the best route to Victory
against Alex Pierre is to get him down
but they didn't give him anybody who can
really wrestle him this was his first
like grappling test in the first round
we're starting the second round but the
first round this guy got him down was
laying on him you're like oh maybe Alex
isn't you get a title shot if he loses
this but you see what happens if you
can't get him down
and he's big dude big with world class
striking he's a problem
oh this is going to be an evenly man oh
he just went oh man
built like a praying mantis no that's it
that's it
praying mantis with an ass job just
oh good grief yeah he do got backs huh
baby got back they'll do that but that
Brazilian water he got that yeah
yeah that Nicki Minaj ass in the UFC so
they're gonna be uh evenly matched and
there's been no wrestling in terms of uh
like the size and reach he's gonna be a
little bigger he's a little heavier he
has more knockout power than izate but
Izzy's more calculated probably more of
a technical Striker because even when
when we'll get to it after the Sean
Strickland fight we're gonna watch Izzy
vs Alex Pierre in the straight oh my God
I was about to say no matter how skilled
you are no matter how big or small
if if one of those gets you anybody
could get taken out of it 100 he ain't
laying down and Izzy you ain't throwing
a jumping neon is the Atlanta bam he's a
problem but again he's a problem if you
play the game if you're there he's a
problem yep that's the kind of movie oh
man that's like a Karate Kid Karate Kid
he might as well just went that's
disrespectful yeah
you know what I mean that was like good
grief man and look up
you show The Karate Kid clip and then
show that that's exactly what he did wow
no he's a problem
let's take another break from chatting
about Izzy and Alex Pierre because I'm
here to talk about the best nootropics
on the planet my friends at on it they
dialed it in they're using the world
renowned nootropic supplement all right
they've sold over 1 million bottles if
you've never heard of nootropics you've
heard of on it well yeah today's your
lucky day because my friends at on it
they got you covered you want better
memory mental speed and focus what if I
told you to take two little pills you
get right into that zone you're knocking
out all the things you gotta do at work
you knocking out your workouts you're
focused you're like well what if it's uh
is there a ton of caffeine my body
doesn't do well with caffeine Alpha
brains caffeine free that's right and
here's how confident my friends at on it
are if you don't love Alpha Brain they
give you your money back no return
necessary give them two weeks tell them
why you don't like it they give your
money back refund whatever you want keep
the bottle we don't care but you're
gonna love it so don't worry about that
Alpha Brain got you covered you can get
10 off on it.com workout gear Warrior
bars protein powder other multivitamins
mc2 oil you can get freaking kettlebells
steel Club maces they got it all but
especially Alpha Branch local Walmart
and pick it up but help your boy out
save temperature off by going to
onit.com
all right or swing by your local Walmart
but help your boy out go to anna.com
shop save 10 off the entire freaking
site especially Alpha Brain now let's
get back to the program that's some [ __ ]
you do in a bar fight it's disrespectful
you do this like messing around too much
and then you just get so they gave Alex
a test now they give them tests in the
top five I think Sean Strickland's
ranked what three here at the time or
four but Sean Strickland likes the likes
the box he likes to like he likes to
strike and bring energy so I had Sean
Striker on the show I went what were you
thinking what's the game plan there goes
[ __ ] the game plan was to like get him
to think I'm striking then take grapple
and wear them out and get them down but
I just kept this is the thing he got
away from the game plan he decided to
keep striking with him he striking them
too long he played with the fire too
long you got burnt did you see he's
coming out here everyone was thinking oh
Sean's gonna shoot right away Sean's
gonna shoot right away but Sean's ego
got involved and he's like not against
his glory yeah he's a glory world
champion I can box with this guy I'm a
good boxer you'll see what happens it's
just not the way to go with it you'll
see his power
and that again this is the first real
Tesla he's not even right he's not even
ranked fighting number four guy in the
world because if he wins this one then
he gets a title shot because the UFC
just needs a narrative of fresh meat
stores to get people excited about Izzy
and they love him Strickland is the
perfect matchup because like oh he'll
play the game with him he's the only guy
in the top five tops eight who will play
the game and I don't like how the other
guy looks like he he's he's very s right
like he's like standing up straight up
straight yeah the other guy feels it
feels like he's yeah he's using his
center of gravity seems better but now
Alex Pierre against Izzy will be upright
as well because he's not worried about
the takedown right which if you're an
Alex Pierre fan you're like yeah that's
exactly what we want see how Sean's like
see how does Patty do against these guys
he's smaller he's way smaller yeah okay
nightmare absolute nightmare all right
yeah yeah that's different do it now
Patty gets on the ground with Alex or
Shawn he's going to submit him but get
him down be a problem all right right
how how much does that hurt those little
politics to the kids like the or when it
happens like whatever but as time goes
on like damn my leg's not really working
and then I've been like I've been like
kicked by gearbox dog and so many times
like this ain't [ __ ] I'm gonna light him
up every time he does it and I was like
I can eat these I have to be in a
wheelchair through the airport I
couldn't walk my legs swelled up my
thighs swelled up how much I couldn't
walk
but it's like it's like an investment
like you're you're doing it because you
think it's a go longer than one round so
those are investments and it stops a guy
from walking forward because if you hit
it hard enough you hit a certain nerve
they're gonna stop coming forward
but see there so they're
they're what was they too about two
minutes and 20 seconds of fight his
coach was like bro Sean take down quit
playing with fire and he's like nah I'm
good man I can do this look I'm having
some success
is he though well you know at least he's
not his my what's the success that he's
had in his mind do you think
right there right there you know like
you played with fire too long yeah he
got burnt
was he trying to say like I'm good yeah
yeah I'm good
over here why why you can't why are you
stopping the fight homie she was like
I'm fine oh man oh man and I don't I
don't like this big booty strut he does
at the end of the fight that praying
mantis big booty look at that big booty
strut around around the ring like that
yep oh this guy's really mad yeah yeah
like that doesn't play well with others
yeah we'll say that okay Maddie lost a
fight like why'd you stop this Furious
what did he say later as he looked at
the tape and he'd be like no you know
you were done on here I asked him I was
like I was like bro what were you
thinking striking him so long he's like
I [ __ ] up he was the game plan was to
strike strike and get him down I struck
too long and I got caught oh oh Jesus
that didn't even that left her again oh
man and you were calling it on Izzy to
the T look boom left hook let that left
Izzy left deadly oh yo you're right yeah
the left it seems to be deadly so with
Izzy Oxford it's gonna be a little
boring of a fight because I don't think
either of them would take a lot of
chances early on because they're such
Elite Strikers oh you know what's crazy
about this one right here that he just
did too it wasn't even in defense no
wide open like he just was like he he's
been he'd been watching him this whole
fight oh boom he looked like he was
going yeah he thought he was going to
the body I I don't you know what I'm not
let's say you know you know you guys
know I'm not an expert
I don't like that dude's techniques
[Laughter]
which one the guy who got knocked out
yeah yeah like his technique
and the guy just waited almost like you
feel like the guy's like all right one
more of those one more yep got him boom
they say come on dude get your Technique
right yeah exactly but for Sean
Strickland it's like Alex Pierre when it
comes to striking he's seen that setup a
thousand [ __ ] times in live hours
like you're knocking out classic get him
down dude yeah and then is that that
guy's ex what's what's Sean Strickland's
expertise
uh pressure and uh volume and he breaks
guys he's tough he's ranked number four
in the world even just how you said that
it doesn't sound like you feel like he
has an expertise no like usually I said
like expertise and you'll be Jiu Jitsu
boxing takedown you just went John
Strickland is here like he like you
literally so that's why you got to knock
him out you got to knock him out
otherwise he's you know you're one of
those guys you got to kill guys
otherwise he keeps coming unfortunately
it's tough he's tough as hell probably
the toughest Middle Way in the world now
so this might get your crunk for the
fight so I'm obviously really high and
Izzy Izzy's barely I don't know what the
odds are barely a slight favorite even
though he's the reigning world champion
at middleweight now when did they fight
what is what is this under this was in I
think it was was it Glory I don't know
what they fought on it was Glory this is
years ago Glory's just kickboxing oh so
they were both world champions and Glory
Alex Pierre this is their second fight
and you'll see so we're gonna see the
Highlight Reel the KO finish
but the thing that people leave out
everyone goes well Alex knocked out
Israel on a Sonya so he can do it with
USC gloves on the problem is if you
don't if you just watch the highlights
which we're gonna do
if you watch the whole fight Izzy's
winning the fight is he's wearing the
fight the whole time and just got caught
yeah well that's what happens in this
sport yeah 100 anybody can get caught at
any time especially at third level yeah
you got suits lit
so there's this younger yeah they're
younger way younger
2017 so you know five years ago oh wow
but you remember you don't forget oh no
no it's in Izzy's mind 100 but look
they're trading back and forth
even though Alex Pierre has board shorts
and what is the difference between this
and the UFC so in this delicious there's
no grappling look at the gloves there's
no takedowns there's no takedowns
there's only kicks punches look at look
at Izzy look at Izzy [ __ ] him up oh
she almost had him out of there twice oh
[ __ ] yeah he's doing work well you'll
see these are bigger gloves too bigger
gloves so you could take a beating more
so than you can because in UFC this guy
oh that's always over over right boom
oh there it is boom Oh my God yeah
they're really going at it so it's
that's the thing that's my whole with
this fight coming up you'll see uh 281
which is on Saturday
um November I think 11th oh my underarm
hurt from that hit this is the thing so
Izzy can play see cats in there Izzy can
play this game is he can play the
Striking with the best of them well I
got a Ruffles like all right you could
get out of here yeah look at that ref
yelling at him
what's he catching with
left hook left that's that dangerous
left that's what we got Strickland with
two yeah
I just feel like we're UFC gloves though
this guy would have got over and overall
that's my whole thing if you watch the
fight everyone was we got knocked out no
I get that if they had small gloves on
it wouldn't even got to this part I
don't think it gets to that point
is he's barely a slight favorite is that
right so they're not crazy odds pretty
especially for a reigning champ because
the odd makers are thinking this can be
an even fight because it's gonna be a
standard what's your thoughts I think
Izzy has the experience especially in
the UFC at a high level Alex Pierre
really hasn't earned his title uh shot I
think it's gonna be too much for him too
soon I think he's being from the bright
lights is he's been there 100 times
before he's flat much tougher guys in
mixed martial arts I think Izzy beats
them okay this does look like it does
look like it's going to be a a excuse me
evenly match fight they seem to do the
same thing they both have a vicious left
this is MMA now I don't give a [ __ ]
about your golden uh Glory Days yeah so
Izzy is 23 and one his one loss was that
light heavyweight outside that he's
never been beat at his weight class Alex
Pierre is six and one okay so so six and
one verse 23. both of these guys have a
lot on the line
yes oh Izzy has more on the line because
Alex yeah he's only six and one it'll be
seven one if he wins is he loses they're
gonna do a rematch
my only thing it's short side with UFC
because let's say Alex bear which I
don't believe this but let's say in some
weird MMA World Alex Pierre has Izzy's
number beats him the first time they do
the rematch his Reign champ beats him
the second time well then you get in the
Marvel inventories the Robert Whittakers
the the Jared canoners the the brunsons
all these guys can grapple and Alex
Spears can be this champ that he's not
gonna be around Long the only guy he
matches up well with is Izzy outside
that all any of the top 10 10 guys you
can grab will beat him you've never seen
him in a grappling match he fought a guy
who was not the best Grappler and he in
the first round the one he knocked the
dude out with the knee that guy won the
first round easily uh he got him down
laid on top of them but Alex is getting
better he trains with Glover attack
Sarah who's the who's fighting for the
light heavyweight title who's a black
belt and grappling and really good at
wrestling like he's he's a beast so I'm
sure he's gotten better but still at
that high level those guys who need him
alive is there a style for grappling
that you can get a belt in
like what is that uh I mean uh sport uh
combat sport like the Dage standings all
have that where they grow up doing it
yeah well yeah that looks like it's
gonna be a good fight great fight oh
dude that card you see anyone's lit yeah
Dustin boy Michael Chandler Frank
Yeagers find that Dan hooker was this
would this be on ESPN plus uh this would
be a pay-per-view on you can uh get on
ESPN plus yeah so there you have it man
it was great so you got Izzy and I'm
telling you he's a great follower he's a
huge anime guy yeah he's on Twitch
he's a beast so uh Eric you're the best
brother thank you hopefully this is one
it won't be a Patty kind of influence
but telling you is what I'm saying is I
I do like I'm interested to see now I'm
interested to see but from doing this
enough times
excuse me from doing this enough times
I'm interested to see
like is we need Izzy to win this fight
yeah so he can move on and do other
great things bigger better things what
I've seen happen in these situations is
yeah he's going to lose uh maybe uh yeah
I don't know you know what I mean a lot
of people and then you're a big fan of
Patty that that Molly the meatball yeah
remember the girl you're like that
girl's [ __ ] tough she's fighting on
this card
yeah Drake bought her a Rolex oh wow but
her and Patty Rolex is for the last wins
because he bet on them which you know
he's got a gambler problem doesn't he I
think I think he's paying this tell him
who to bet on he probably doesn't watch
I know but he just won like 12 million
dollars on something yeah man it's good
to be great I'm not gonna be surprised
I'm gonna be like is that Drake at a
like a UPS you know because he just lost
all his money
but that's uh yep UFC 281 enjoy it see
ya thank you Eric we're out
[Music]
oh
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding